here's what I need to establish because
this has been the issue which people
have been uh I think rightly concerned
about which is all this money is £89,000
in the first year that club Nook limited
raised in Revenue where did that come
from because the belief is it came from
Captain Tom themed merchandise is that
the case no that that the money hasn't
come from merchandise the bulk of that
money the vast majority of that came
from the three books that he
wrote um with penguin Random House the
Captain Tom wrote the that Captain Tom
wrote including one was a big runaway
number one besteller yeah so tomorrow
will be a good day which is his
autobiography which is about his life um
and what percentage of the club money
was from those books 95% of it so the
vast majority yeah was there any other
merchandise themed product no never any
no no so Club nut never made any revenue
from Captain Tom the merchandise outside
of these books no so Hannah the question
I guess about the books
is people will say well the books are
based on his Fame which came from the
charity walks why has that money not
gone to
charity these um were my father's books
and and it was honestly such a joy for
him to write them but they were his
books they um the deal was done he had
an agent and the agent um and he worked
on that deal they were Captain Tom's
books and his wishes whether that money
was that that money would sit in club
nuk and in the end um for you to keep
yes he said that specifically to you
specifically was there anything on any
of the books that referred to the
Captain Tom Foundation absolutely not
was there anything in the contracts that
referred to Captain foundation so there
was never any agreement by you on behalf
of your father with these book deals
that any of that money would go to
charity absolutely not and remember that
he wrote these books um he started
writing them fairly early on um just as
the walk had finished and they were all
signed off he'd finished them by the
June of
2020 um they they were never anything to
do with the charity what will you say to
people who'll say you shouldn't have
kept that money that it should have all
gone to the Char that these books were
based on Captain Tom it's the public are
buying the books it should all have gone
to charity what will you say to those
but they were my father's books um he
wrote them and he decided what to do
with the income from them it was his
wishes not not ours he made the decision
about the things that he did we um
didn't act for
him Colin I mean people will criticize
this you know that but are you
comfortable looking back would you do
the same thing again given all the
attention that's now being put on you as
a family all the
criticism would you if you had your time
again keep that money yes you know they
were it was his money his income and
just because the charity happened to be
called Captain Tom Foundation doesn't
mean that his assets are all suddenly be
owned
by